today we're going to be speaking with
andy norman who studies how ideologies
can
short-circuit minds he's the author of
the recently released book
mental immunity infectious ideas mind
parasites
and the search for a better way to think
andy it's so great to have you on today
thank you david it's a pleasure to be
here you know there's all these
analogies
these days uh to infection
and immunity and and inoculation and
vaccination and you talk about the
concept of
a mental immune system and a cultural
immune system can you tell us a little
bit about those ideas
yeah so just as our bodies have immune
systems that protect us from infectious
microbes
our minds have immune systems that
protect us from infectious ideas
these immune systems aren't talked about
a great deal in the sciences yet but the
sciences are waking up
to the fact that that they exist there's
now a mountain of
evidence that they do exist and had to
exist
because the wrong ideas could get our
ancestors killed
um and so we're learning to actually
science is actually learning to view
minds
as having filtering systems that are
meant to fact to screen out bad ideas
and let in good ones
and of course they can malfunction in
all kinds of ways that lead to social
dislocation and uh political
uh turmoil among other things so
sometimes people will ask me
you know what what is the best way to
protect oneself from
fake news and disinformation propaganda
etc
and in my mind the inoculation that i
suggest
is a foundation of critical thinking
and understanding how we evaluate
whether something we've been told is
something we should believe
and understanding how media works and
and media literacy
is that an example of such an immune
system
absolutely so i think the concept that
comes closest
to mental immunity is critical thinking
uh and and so if you want to get a good
head start on an understanding of mental
immunity start with critical thinking
for sure
it turns out though that the concept of
critical thinking is a very crude
instrument
for helping to build mental immunity
and and it turns out the critical
thinking skills can be weaponized for an
ideology
not just employed to create fair-minded
uh thinkers can you give an example of
how of how that can happen
well sure so i think universities have
been cranking out people who are
trained to one another degree in
critical thinking for
decades and decades and often what
happens is that i meant
that a college graduate will
use their ability to dissect arguments
to defeat arguments they dislike but
not employ them to clarify or modify
their own thinking
so is that sort of a confirmation type
bias use of a tool
exactly so psychologists call
confirmation bias the tendency to
basically let in information that fits
your
political or ideological preconceptions
let those in uncritically but then
respond critically or cynically
to information that that challenges your
point of view
and the problem with that is it's a
recipe for closed-mindedness and tribal
tribal thinking and we absolutely need
to get past that
if we hope to actually become wiser
versions of ourselves
when it comes to specific rhetorical
tactics i'd be curious to see what you
found about
what is more effective versus what is
less effective
we've talked on the program about things
like using a socratic method of
questioning to get
one to re-examine their own beliefs and
come to the conclusion themselves that
they may be mistaken this is sort of
in a sense i think an idea from dale
carnegie from the 30s or whenever he
wrote
how to win friends and influence people
um the defeasibility question which is
what evidence if it existed would get
you
to change your mind and then using that
like as a jumping off point i mean
are these are these tools may be
effective
uh absolutely so in the book i argue
that the
famous socratic method basically a way
of testing ideas with questions and
seeing
if they can withstand questioning that
that's one of the most powerful mind
inoculants ever invented
and in the book i take that mind
inoculant and refine it into something i
call the new socratic method
which i argue can be something like a
mind vaccine
and take our critical thinking to a
whole new level
um i also love the question what would
change your mind
that that is a powerful question for
both
strengthening and modulating mental
immune systems
so just as the the body's immune system
can get out of
kilter and attack the body's own tissues
or let in covid
right let in the coronavirus the mind's
immune system can get it
confused and attack the wrong things so
a conspiracy theorist is somebody who
becomes hypercynical about
traditional or mainstream sources of
information and their own critical
mindset is almost like an autoimmune
disorder i was going to say it's it's
almost like this cytokine storm
we talk about with the pandemic where
the immune system goes crazy because
they're they're you know for whatever
reason i'm not a doctor but uh
like this overactive defense mechanism
that's exactly exactly the right analogy
so cytokines are actually
antibodies uh the the things the mind
the body's immune system produces to
fight off what it perceives to be a
threat
and sometimes the body's immune system
overreacts to something that's genuinely
harmless
so when you have an allergic reaction to
pollen
that's your body overreacting to
something that really doesn't harm it
it's the overreaction that makes you
miserable right and our minds can make
the exact
same kind of mistake we can attack
genuinely reliable information because
it comes from somebody on the other side
of the political divide say
and in this way our minds do more to
protect our chosen identities
than they do to actually help us find
the truth you actually have to train
your
mind's immune system to care about
truth and to care less about your
ideological identity
and when you do that you become wiser
yeah the conspiracy theory thing is
interesting
we've interviewed experts on
conspiracism and conspiratorial thinking
and they're you know what how can you
distinguish between
healthy skepticism and what's on the
other side which is this never-ending
and unsatisfiable cynicism which is
often what is at the core of
conspiratorial thinking
yeah you're exactly right um i think
it's long been a tenet of the critical
think
of of critical thinking advocates that
we think critically we ask the right
questions but those other guys
right um they're insufficiently critical
but it turns out you can be too critical
for your own good just as it's possible
to be under critical it's possible to be
over critical
um and so the a truly healthy
mind is one that strikes the right
balance between suspicion and trust
yeah that uh you know the
a lot of this as you sort of alluded to
is
i my family is a huge mental health
family a lot of people inv you know
psych psychiatry psychologist et cetera
and there's this really common
psychotherapy question which is
what would it mean to you if what you
believe isn't true which is really about
one's identity kind of being tied up
in their beliefs and so that's probably
to some degree at the core of why
we attach so much to the beliefs we come
in with and are
and those beliefs are resistant to
change that
that's right and it turns out that we're
more attuned to the usefulness
of ideas than we are to their truth so
an idea feels useful to us a lot of
times we'll cling to it
even after it's been debunked right
and and but to genuinely uh deepen your
understanding of the world
and to become to grow morally you
actually have to learn to care
as much or more about truth as you do
about
the usefulness of the ideas that fill
your health your head
i should say by the way that genuinely
wise people don't look only
at what i call upstream evidence for
truth they also
care about the downstream causal
consequences of what we believe
right both matter
the you know i'm thinking of the idea
that some
hold people who are economically
disadvantaged
that it's you know immigrants from
mexico
that are responsible for them either not
having a job
or having lost a job or or whatever the
case may be
and that seems to fit that idea that you
mention of
there's a convenience to believing that
that there's a usefulness to that
because maybe it takes attention away
from
other economic factors that are truly
responsible
or from whatever personal responsibility
there may be
behind one's economic circumstances
whatever whatever the truth is
that that's exactly right so scapegoat
scapegoating immigrants
is uh has long been a staple of
demagogues and what it does is it
is that it very reliably hijacks
mental immune systems of the demagogues
supporters
so if you peddle fear of immigrants
a lot of times the fear will uh trigger
autoimmune cognitive autoimmune
overreactions
right thereby duping your own followers
and by hearing by your followers i mean
a demagogue's followers one's followers
yeah
one's followers right um so so fear
mongers
actually are hijacking the minds of
their own
followers and many of us in america
right now
are easily triggered by the
propagandists
on our side of the aisle i know that i
catch myself all the time
um overreacting to the fear-mongering
of the some of the progressive activists
that i
tend to trust and respect
what about situations where maybe two
people with different views enter
uh to a conversation in good faith
really wanting to sort of like hash out
what what is the truth
and you get to this situation where it's
sort of like my source versus your
source and
we get through these initial steps where
we ask the questions on
what are you basing your view on and i
tell you what i'm basing my view on and
you tell me and the sources just sort of
conflict and of course
a really deep study might show us the
ways in which statistics may have been
manipulated or whatever but it sort of
starts to get
we we end up in the weeds so to speak
what is it
what should be done in that case how can
we move forward towards truth in
situations like that
yeah um so
to actually work through such
disagreements in conversation requires
patience and the kind of patience that
we seem to have
forgotten the virtue of in this in these
breakneck times
um but it but in principle right every
one of us now
can fact check things by pulling a
device out of our pockets and starting
to google things
but the thing to understand is that
there's a ton of unreliable information
out there and a lot of it
is on very slick websites or in
carefully
manipulated statistical analyses so as
to get you
to support one or another political or
religious ideology right
so so you need to be very skeptical
you need to look closely at the sources
you tend to rely on both online and in
the mainstream media
and and do your fact checking find out
which ones are really reliable and ask
yourself
who benefits from peddling this kind of
information
and and what interest what incentives
might they have
for skewing it in a way that that might
manipulate
me last thing i wanted to ask you about
um there there's sometimes there's talk
of sort of like
benign conspiratorial beliefs and often
the one that's cited is
like flat earth as an example someone
who believes flat earth it's
okay you know it's kind of wacky but it
really
is not damaging but then the counter
that i've heard frequently is
someone who believes that likely doesn't
believe
only that and flat earth and
anti-semitism
have huge overlap etc how should we
evaluate like which battles are worth
fighting
and and sort of adjudicating some of the
because there's just so much
that could be focused on and and kind of
thinking through that
fantastic question david um so a
canadian research team just came out
last year with a study that shows that
if you indulge in irresponsible thinking
in one domain
you weaken your mind's immune system in
ways that
compromise your ability to distinguish
fact from fiction in other domains
right so if you indulge in wishful
thinking
for the sake of of
of harmony with your co-religionists
you end up becoming more susceptible to
conspiracy thinking
more susceptible to science denial more
susceptible to propaganda
so you you can't say oh i'll just go off
and
indulge in uh wishful thinking in this
domain and expect it not to compromise
uh your your mental function um
so i actually argue in the book that
there's our minds have a lynch
our mental immune systems have a
linchpin and that linchpin is
always yield to the better reason never
let wishful thinking
dissuade you from doing the right thing
which is to believe
uh as much as possible on the basis of
the best reasons and evidence available
uh so you when you begin to move away
from
evidence-based thinking you start to
compromise your mind's funk
your mind's immune functioning and
don't think you can only go a little
ways down this path
and and not slide further down that path
because the evidence shows that the
slope can become very slippery
yeah it seems like some sometimes going
to a slippery slope
is itself fallacious but in this case it
seems to really be a core
a core aspect of how that works uh the
book is called
mental immunity infectious ideas mind
parasites and the search for a better
way to think
we've been speaking with the book's
author andy norman really great having
you on i so appreciate your time
thank you david it's been a pleasure